number have you have you talked to Ari
yeah how is he doing he's I just I just
sat at the cellar with him for a little
while he's doing good good yeah it seems
like he's I don't I you know Ari didn't
wasn't online
he wasn't online when all the hate was
coming his way
so I think whereas we might have seen it
he didn't see any of it so he's like was
it bad it was almost like I love there's
almost like someone that was in a coma
and then wakes up and they're like and
like goes hey we're all the people
they're like oh there was a pandemic was
it bad yeah and so he's he does not I
think he's still doing shows under a
fake name
alright but uh but it's probably he
probably fears some sort of like
physical backlash maybe yeah but he's I
mean he's planning a big tour there I
mean like a theater tour and tour bus
and Wow he's planning a really big tour
so I you know I think he might be he was
a really interesting guy to talk to
during that whole thing's like I called
him he got upset with me because he
thought I didn't call him I called him
the day it [ __ ] happened and the day
after I called him that Monday and and
he was like and he was upset he's like
you should reach out me and I was like I
[ __ ] did [ __ ]
so I think it was a very confusing kind
of like emotionally turbulent time for
him and I think he knew ship was going
on but he didn't want to look you know
yeah it's almost like it's almost like
like he was in a in like like he locked
in the house and there was a riot going
on outside and he didn't want to look
out for a little bit so but he had the
emotional turmoil of knowing there was a
riot going on outside
they all said then it became a safety
issue too I think that's what right now
is maybe a safety issue that's the way
it goes with by a different name right
is I forget what his name is I Persians
[Laughter]
but now I'm a big fan of your wife I
love her I anyway my wife would [ __ ]
love you
but does she I know that the whole re oh
she hates his guts okay yeah she hates
him in a way that not many people she's
all she really hates him like really
hates him and that was what bothered me
about when he molly'd me was
I was like I was like the it's so funny
he wants me to release the podcast I
will never release that [ __ ] podcast
it does not look make him look it not
only does it not make him look good
first of all it's proof that he
committed a crime that's number one
and and and number two it's just it he's
like it's funny he's funny and I know
it's not because you see in my eyes a
person who thinks I might die and you
can see that and I see it clearly but
you also see like me realizing re just
[ __ ] up our friendship and I and and I
and I was like that's what bothered me
the most out of it it's like when it
happened I go you just made it so my
kids will hate you and now my wife will
hate you and you can never come to my
house and I can never go on vacation
with you cuz my wife will always go
don't go I don't want you going yeah and
you also made it so I don't really feel
safe around you entirely and I was like
I get in the podcast I kept going why
would you do this like why this I don't
know let me just get just so you do a
podcast with Ari yeah in his house it is
in your house in my house and how did he
slip you the Molly so I I set it up I
was like I was getting ready to start my
tour that's why I said this is gonna be
awesome I'll do a podcast vari I'll have
a few drinks I'll get on a plane we'll
smoke cigars this is great I wouldn't
seen him in a while
him and LeAnn are starting to patch
things up heavenly I had a falling out
before because Ari had commented on
George's teeth Georgia teeth are great
now but she was at younger she anemone
enamel on her teeth and they didn't look
great I posted a picture of me and her
in Hawaii and Ari was like way to have
ugly snow stupid [ __ ] teeth no that
is absolutely beyond crossing the line
for me that's the same reason why I
don't post a lot of stuff about my
family yeah cuz I'm fair game you can do
say anything you want about me but if
you come for anybody in my family a [ __ ]
no for me well I think that's our our
ease our ease response by the way I have
defended Ari so much in my life that I
now I just I go blame Hitler it's
Hitler's fault Hitler did this Hitler's
dad put or his dad and Hitler put
Artie's dad in the concentration camp
yeah and so and so his dad was the
concentration camp survivor you
you know that comes with some baggage
you know that being the son of a
concentration camp survivor is it gonna
be trauma there's and so part of what is
wrong with Ari is there he was Orthodox
Jewish and he lost his religion and
there's a lot at the Glenn Miller anyway
so he did that and then I was like
[ __ ] Ari the ants aren't wearing why
she was livid [ __ ] livid so I took
take the picture down call Ari I go bro
don't [ __ ] why would you do that he was
like but it's a joke and I was like it's
not a joke my daughter would have seen
that he goes don't post your daughter on
line
don't post your daughter on line ah I
was like Ari I was like listen you need
to apologize LeeAnn and he was like why
it was a joke and I was like okay all
right so then I finally broke her an
apology at Segura's house with Ari in
the end I say this is the first time
we're gonna do so Brock to her I said
land the girls there Ari I want you to
go into the kitchen I want you to
apologize Lee and say I'm sorry I did
that and he goes okay I still don't
think I should and I was like Ari you
should just do it please it'll make my
life easier then I can be your friend
because my wife eights you would be
friends so Tom and I and Kristina and my
daughters all go to the backyard to let
our apologize Liam or it comes out and
goes I did it you're welcome I don't
thank you thank you yeah we walk inside
and LeAnn it's like it's a joke
I guess I'm sorry but I mean it was a
joke if you think of the joke I don't
know what to tell you sensitivity other
people's feelings Oh [ __ ] just like
so then so then so finally finally we
get to a place where Leanne is like you
know whatever he was I guess he thought
it was a joke wasn't a joke we're fine
he comes over our house a couple times I
was laundry at our house cuz you know
he's like a vagabond
we don't hikes me and him go on a trip
together to Utah and LeAnn's now back
cool yeah so I said
I you know what this would be cool
because the girls love re
the girls loved re they do not anymore
and so I come over we'll do a podcast
hop back we'll smoke cigar get a little
pause bring them in Leanne's gonna make
dinner from re me the girls will all
have dinner the girls love having dinner
with my friends like that it's a lot of
fun for them because they see a part of
my personality the comedic personality
but untethered in that guy and it's fun
it's always fun they had dinner with
Stanhope and it was like one of the
favorite dinners a bow and so um so I go
back and re is doing something by the
bar it looks suspicious I mean honestly
I I it looked super super suspicious but
I in my million years I never thought he
would drug me in a million [ __ ] years
I need a million [ __ ] years and he
goes hey let's do a let's do a
celebratory shot you know start a
podcast I was like okay and he goes it's
a was a really good with not whiskey uh
scotch and I hate scotch
I don't like taste scotch so you okay so
I take the test gosh and it I could
taste something was wrong with it but I
just wrote it off the scotch I was like
I [ __ ] hate scotch
I was it goes to the podcast we started
on the podcast and then like it and he's
doing this like weird [ __ ] where he's
like yeah and I'm like and I'm watching
him going like what the [ __ ] are you
doing and then at one point I go are you
on something and he just goes are you on
something and I go no and he goes are
you sure and I went yeah I'm certain and
he goes are you hundreds a jerk because
there's something I need to tell you and
you gotta you can't get mad about it and
I went what he goes I slipped you Molly
and I immediately my heart [ __ ] sank
and I went all I could think was that
kid that young writer from New York went
down to Mexico took Molly and died right
and I immediately I'm like oh my god I'm
on blood pressure medicine I'm this may
interact my blood pressure medicine my
face is now feeling really really hot I
have a [ __ ] spinning out of control
panic attack book my first thought was
this isn't gonna end well like it with
my fit you were supposed to stay for
dinner like this was my piece was gonna
be brokered it and I was like leeanne's
never gonna oh this is gonna be really
bad and I'm
and I'm doing all the math and then I'm
doing what could you have pretended that
you weren't on it know what your Molly
baby you're like two steps away from
like dry humping you know a fig tree and
it's an it's hard it's hard to
compartmentalize because on one side
you're upset the other side you're on
Molly so you're like feel great like I
remember thinking I'm ever thinking oh
you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I said
to him that and then I go but your your
your eyes are beautiful and but he was
he was not he was not he's not he was
not he didn't realize he had done
something wrong and to like almost like
a week later a week later he called me
and he was like I think he texted me and
he was like and I wasn't talking to him
like I was really upset with him and he
was like I feel like I [ __ ] up our
friendship I was like you think like no
[ __ ] like and he was like I'm really
upset about it I'm really upset that I
messed up our friendship I didn't know
what was gonna I just wanted to have a
good time with you you're the best guy
and like we didn't talk for a month and
it was during sober October I didn't
talk to him also rocktober and then and
I mean LeAnn was I told the Anna why I
did it play out that day they're like
when did he tell Ian like hey I got slip
tamale I might act weird so I had to get
ready for a flight I had to fly that
night so I'm now I'm freaking out I
don't like flying let alone I like
flying on my darling
yeah no no that doesn't help it out so
Joey Diaz comes over Joey Diaz sits down
I think Joey Diaz I'm gonna take a Molly
to like just make sure we're all cool my
cousin came over and then Joey and I I
walk everyone out and I said you already
just leave do not say anything to anyone
just leave this [ __ ] house so I walk
him out him and Joey out I then take Lee
Lee Ann's like are you wanna stay for
dinner and he's like no and just walked
out she was like what's wrong with Ari
and I was like nothing I do I need to
talk to you the bat in the bathroom so I
bring in the bathroom Oh Mike I'm with
my cousin I think with my cousin and I
said I'm gonna tell you something and
you can't have emotions about it she was
like sorry
and she was like yeah yeah yeah I go
thing to do I go I need you to take care
of me right now and not and not go off
off the handle and she said what and
then I said I already slept me Molly and
she was like who is he like wow okay
[Laughter]
what do you need for me and I said I
need to be packed and I need to get on a
plane tonight
she went okay I said you got to get me
out of the house without talking to the
girls I don't wanna talk to the girls
because I'm really [ __ ] up she was
like okay
and so she packed a bag for me I took a
shower it was a great [ __ ] shower
yeah and and then she got me out the
door and then I went straight to the
store
and then the first person I ran into
because I was way too early for the
flight and I didn't want to be in an
airport I wanted to get to the airport
literally get there and go straight to
the plane so I go to the store and I run
into David Spade and Ahri's back in the
back bar and Whitney's back in the back
bar and I'm still on Molly and I'm like
and I'm telling the story and where
everyone's laughing and are he's like
that's fine fine it's fine
but I'm still really sitting then I then
I get to we get on a plane dude sit next
me gets the best massage anyone's ever
had and I get to the vent I get to the
place pass out wake up the next day and
I am a [ __ ] mess like my OCD is all
over the place might I don't really deal
with much with depression I guess I
don't know what it is for me it
manifests itself in panic and OCD and I
was a [ __ ] mess we had a reviving
rally that blood fluids people show up
they gave me an IV I felt a little
better but I couldn't write the boat it
was like for like for like a week almost
I would say I was just like and Artie
was like that was the biggest mistake I
made I should have given you 5-htp I was
like yeah I was like sure yeah but Liam
was I got home and when I got home she
was like she's like you're done you're
done with that guy no but you never
speak to him I yeah I was like you can't
I was like listen I need to make that
decision not you and I may not make that
decision and I didn't make that decision
I there's a part of us that and I know
you know this too is there always a
really [ __ ] sweet guy
times like he's such a great great great
great guy that's super sensitive it's
super sweet but there's this other guy
that he does where it's like it's just
stubbornness that he has yeah and you
just go like and as a friend you go I
want I want to help I don't know it's
like but I think that might piss him off
even more if you don't meet him where
he's at like you can't meet him where
you want him to be you got to meet him
exactly where he's at if he's gonna he's
gonna slip you a Molly that day that's
where you're at and he's gonna be sweet
to you and that's where you got to just
take it for what he is that day
definitely don't want him as an enemy
because when he was beating the [ __ ] out
well that's not a friendship then if you
fear retaliation from somebody and then
you treat them you know politically
nicely because you think that there's
well no Ari and I were like best friends
for like seven yeah I was there when he
first started right so when I would go
on the road we would go together we've
had we've had sex with the different
women in rooms together and we've had a
lot of good times and then when he
brutally beat the SH out of me three
weeks in a row and then I had him banned
from the comedy store and then when he
came back for seven or eight years after
that he just was so mean to me when cuz
when you're on his bad side he would
walk by you're a piece of [ __ ] you're
not funny you shouldn't be here you're
you know man you're dumb you know you're
dumb you know I went to college and why
and he would say that even when we had
this like no talking no truths kind of
you know I mean a truce kind of a thing
but then you know once and I hated him I
[ __ ] I didn't hate any I hated I
hated him more than Hitler oh yeah yeah
and I never knew Hitler but my point is
to the stories though this sounds even
fun more [ __ ] up coming for me I've
never had bad experiences with already
other than him Molly me but I don't
think I really genuinely don't think he
put any thought into it other than this
is gonna be awesome it's Bert he's the
Machine he parties all the time yeah he
can handle Molly it's only half a hit no
one dies from Molly me and him are gonna
have a [ __ ] blast I don't think he
thought I know he didn't think he's on
blood-pressure medicine
his kids are in the house his wife's
making us dinner he has to be on a plane
tonight I
he thought we'll do this we'll go out
we'll party all night he didn't think
through all the actions so for stuff
like that and you know I've known him
for so long I've never had anything
other than this very sweet loving
friendship with him but I have to say
when he called me seven or eight years
later and he said listen I'm sorry
you hear me and he goes you know I'm
doing this show this and that I want you
on it I want you to tell the story you
know whatever and we got together and
then I realized that he was Sikh put his
hand around me and he goes I'm so sorry
I love you man I was [ __ ] crazy eight
years Wow you know I mean and then might
now it's my experiences with him since
then has been that sweet old glory that
I once knew back in the day you know so
um you know I think he's changed a lot
but um when I heard about well obviously
the Kobe thing was like wow but then
when I heard about you what him on you
it was just like a little it just sounds
just a little weird to me I mean it the
thing that had the thing that a few
people that I that I trust and I and I
loved that I know very well thing that a
few people put my head was that it was
about jealousy and that because we had
just gone hung out and I was he was in
Madison
I was doing the theater and he was doing
the club and I had a tour bus and and we
were hanging out ari was very very real
not like not in a bad way but very real
like wow like this is it this is so cool
man I so cool the of a tour bus like he
walked out and he looked at the theater
and he's like just a lot of [ __ ]
people to come to see you on a Thursday
night sold out he walked on the stage
and thought like it he got a big cheer
and like no one really knew who he was
and so when see people started going he
was jealous I was like that's not Ari
I'm in my experience it's not Ari yeah
then you but then when you're coming off
Molly and your [ __ ] brains not right
yeah I start going you start going
jealousy is real a real motion people do
get jealous you can't deny it
I've been jealous with people and I'm a
good person
why shouldn't maybe that was retaliation
for him to go you know what you think
you're hot stuff now now you're back to
me now I'm in control of you so there
was a real
thing going on in my head and that was
the first thing or he said he was like
he was like you have to know that like
it was nothing about jealousy I don't I
have to accept arias word for what it is
and that he just thought it was gonna be
a great time and I and he really
miscalculated with Leanne on this I can
appreciate a complex man I can
appreciate all sorts of complex
personalities but that is diabolical
because when you involve the kids in
someone's home that is that's to me
that's poisonous also because I I'm on
blood pressure medication myself imagine
if that happened to me
this is I'm glad Leanne is a really
rational I would actually physically
fight him I will put all my Filipino
power into these fists and I will
[ __ ] telling especially cuz I'm sober
if I was sober babe babe if I was sober
the way I'm now yeah I know
I mean Leanne said that Leanne said this
is the one that really got me and this
is what I this is what the this is what
made me mad at Ari was that I had to
have conversations like this we're
sitting my sister's house and Ari text
me and I and I grab my phone and I start
to reply my daughter Georgia takes the
phone away from me she goes don't talk
to that guy Georgia she goes no no and I
go George she goes he almost killed my
dad so how about Joe and I went I went
[ __ ] Ari like in my head I go
you didn't I didn't have to have this
conversation
my daughter's loved you they thought you
were [ __ ] hilarious and now they hate
you and then and then George goes dad
what would you do if someone molly'd me
and then I I said I'd [ __ ] I would
kill them and I would find out fine what
they loved and I would break it I would
break what they loved and Georgia said
George goes and then what would you do
if you saw me texting with them after
they had molly'd me I went and then I
was like god dammit why the [ __ ] do you
have to be yeah yeah I look love re
Italy they were so similar so there are
so many parts of the
little brains there but I remember one
time I walked in and they were talking
about how to put on deodorant to each
other like just independently oh no I
love [ __ ] hates his guts Wow and it's
and that's what sucks about this whole
[ __ ] thing is that like I didn't get
to have emotions about it cuz I had to
take care of everyone else had to take
care of to take care of an the girls
didn't want them to find out in when
they didn't find out they're like the
first thing they said was they go Oh
everyone schools talking about it we
know that re-roof e to you and raped you
in the backyard I'll go hold on Ruby
don't know they're irate I was like you
thought Laurie help me down the back so
yeah it was super complex you know what
sucks about this whole thing
dude the real thing that sucks is is
that I'm I've always been nice to you
yeah have a not yeah like a little
yellow creature of the night right I'm
like a mythological angel uh-huh
right hug on you yeah have I ever tried
a Molly you know no I've only been
gentle I've never been invited your
house I've never been invited your house
for dinner I've never tried Molly and
this is how broken my brain is about
trust I went oh my god it's in the ice
[Laughter]
yeah